[Music]
[Applause]
but let's bring in chris sims pro
football talk live where where do you
stand on that question chris
well as far as the afc south's concerned
and good to see you or uh good to see
you dan but
you know i don't think he'll have an
issue with that i mean the titans still
have
so many things to like about their
football team and of course
you know defensive line lack of pass
rushers disrupters
secondary the defense needs to be
improved there you know jj
watt fits into any scheme he can do four
three three four i think that's why you
see so many teams
interested in him and yeah that history
between mike frable
there is certainly something there to it
and really the way houston
has run their organization here the last
few years
i'm not so sure jj wouldn't like going
to play tennessee and sticking it to
them here you know uh
oh you mean the texans i mean the texans
yeah sorry
yes yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't be
shocked if you wouldn't mind sticking it
to them and just going hey you know
here i am i'm with a winner eat that but
i wonder
if you know we always say well it's not
always about money it always feels like
it's about money
jj watts made 100 million dollars in his
career
how important is winning and if that's
the case why not go to
why not say to the kansas city chiefs
hey whatever you want to pay me i'm
coming there we're winning a
championship
i i agreed you know i don't think that's
crazy i mean green bay
up there they could use guys they have
they still have deficiencies
as far as their interior part of their
defense aligned
and at this point of his career you you
kind of said it right dan
he's got a ton of money you know i don't
think that
should be or at least if i was in his
situation wouldn't be the make or break
point
to me it'd be hey pay me something
respectful or you know
respectful and you know i'll try to add
to your team
you know jj watts still a really good
player but we know he has had a little
bit of
injury history over the last few years
and his production has fallen off i mean
for the sac master he was
you know i think he's had 26 and a half
sacks or someone there
somewhere around there over the last
five years so he's not the same guy he
was
but i certainly do think he brings value
to a team i can't imagine
a team paying him 15 16 million dollars
a year at this
point i'm not sure if i believe those
reports yet i i'd have to hear something
a little more substantial to believe
that one
when do you buy into a mock draft or
mock drafts
um not right yet i know that
but like at what point in the process do
you go
that might be a little truer
representation of what teams are going
to do
i would say when you get to those last
two or three weeks
before the draft there's just too many
unknowns right now you know one
uh and no disrespect but there's so many
media outlets
there there's a lot of people who you
know are not the best evaluators or
qualified to do that
uh so i want to be like okay i mean you
don't know and
and then the other thing i think that's
that's into this and and
the teams don't know yet they're really
the teams are just starting to dive into
the draft themselves here
it's been free agency figuring out our
own team
what do we need how are we going to
balance the salary cap and all those
things too
so that of course once they start to
figure out the draft
it filters out to the people i do
respect in the business you know the
danielle jeremiah's and those guys they
start to get a feel for what they're
hearing from teams
and then those that that's the time when
i start to go oh okay
all right i'll i'll pay attention to
that mock draft oh there's some logic
there i know he knows this team
so there's something there to that and
that's when i start to really pay
attention but you get this
this guy's rising this guy's falling
well they haven't played a game in
months
and it feels like we're getting to the
point when
the you know the coaches of the gm's or
the scouts are able to be
get a better handle on assessing just
how good these players are like mac
jones at alabama
all of a sudden mac jones is moving up
like what did mac jones do
or not do that makes him you know rise
up in the first round
well i think that i think like kind of
what i just said is there's too many
and again i'm not there's just too many
unqualified
people making qualifying statements at
times here and just
oh yeah mac jones end of the first round
i've i've said it
every day this week i said it on my
podcast mac jones
from and i'm early here dan i've just
started
i've really only looked at like good
throws of these quarterbacks i'm about
to dive in here
mac jones is a better prospect than tua
mac jones is going to go in the top 10
from just what i've seen right now i'd
be shocked
i think there's going to be four
probably in the top eight just just a
base comment right now and you can have
me on in a few weeks and i'll really get
into the nitty-gritty with these
quarterbacks and give you a great
breakdown and all those type of things
but
um i think that's what it is and i think
what you're hearing
rising is what we just talked about too
now some of the people in the media are
talking to people in the nfl who have
just started to turn on the film and
they're going
this mac jones guy all he does is throw
spirals perfect throws nfl type throws
he can change his arm angle and do those
type of things
and i think that's why you're kind of
hearing that that chatter right now yeah
but he was throwing to guys who were i
mean i know when's the last time a
french
you know a team had four first-round
draft picks over the
you know a two-year period and that's
what you're gonna have with alabama
i i get you i i know you know it's it's
uh
hey you know me i was not a huge tua guy
last year by any stretch of the
imagination i was all joe burrow and
herbert i thought they were special
you know i made a lot of statements that
herbert i thought had the higher ceiling
than joe burrow in the draft and those
type of things
it's hey trevor lawrence got talent
around him too in clemson
i think when it goes down to it it's
about okay
you know what was available what was
there to be had did he take advantage of
all that was there to be had
you've heard me say this before when
there's nothing there to be had
what happens and then can i see
nfl type throws that i think translate
you know from college to the nfl and
that was my
you know my my hesitation with tua last
year but i saw enough just in the little
clips i've seen and just
tv scouting during the year where
pockets collapsing
things aren't perfect and he can still
make a high-level throw to why i went
ooh
i like that about him yes you're gonna
have to take into account
those type of things the talent around
them and all of that and of course
waddle uh who was hurt most of the year
yeah he's gonna be
you know a top 20 pick and devante
smith's going to be a top 20 pick too
like these two receivers he had to play
with this year
i think are better than jerry judy and
henry ruggs i'll just say that right off
the bat
so he certainly had help but that's part
of evaluating and you just got to take
you know the best of what you can and
see does that translate to
nfl football life he's chris sims pro
football talk
live um mike florio said yesterday
doesn't think desean watson gets traded
oh um i'm not so sure i'm ready to go
down that
that lane yet i'm not i i have on pretty
good info
that desean watson is not afraid to sit
out the year uh i really do i've heard
that from people i really trusted
in league circles but also chris and i
want to be fair to florio
you know he said look they may be saying
hey we're not taking offers
while they are taking offers but doesn't
it make the most sense for the texans
to say what detroit did with matthew
stafford
we're open for business because teams
are going to start signing up free
agents
they're going to get ready for the draft
and then all of a sudden i limit
the pool of resources of teams that
might be giving you
a true treasure trove for deshaun watson
i i don't understand
you know the timing of it is curious i i
don't either and listen i'm not trying
to you know push back on mike i mean
mike's got a great feel for the league
he knows people
everything i know and this is why he
said it and i think he's heard that
we've heard the same things because
we've talked about this on our show
the texans aren't they're not open for
business like uh
i know some of these teams that are
interested in deshaun watson
and they've they've you know led me to
believe that that they don't think the
texans are doing anything right now
i'm more of what you're saying i would
go
what like let's get denver and the
carolina panthers and the miami dolphins
you know into you know a bidding war
here
so we can maximize what we get for
desean watson
because i again the the the the
organization's dysfunctional down there
there's a lot of people and players on
that team that don't want to be there
but they're not desean watson
he has the support from players on his
team who have told them like hey go
we understand you want to get out of
here we get it uh and
it's always dangerous to bring that kind
of
player quarterback back into your locker
room as you know
when he's upset or doesn't like being
there you know he's the leader of the
team
he's going to start trashing coaches and
the owner and the gm
and things like that and it's going to
embolden the rest of the locker room and
it's gonna make things more
dysfunctional
so that's where i think you're you know
to your point i i would start opening up
business now and start getting those
conversations going
yesterday i said i didn't understand
what the steelers were doing with ben
roethlisberger they're not winning
a championship another championship with
him you want to bring him back farewell
tour that's one thing
but i think bringing him back no matter
what the salary is
it also will probably hamper you the
followings
now like right i i got to get started
here
uh you know can you keep bud dupree you
got some younger players there
now's the time to win and you might be
the third best team
in your own division and ben might be
the fourth best quarterback
in his own division so explain the logic
of what the steelers are doing and am i
too critical on what they're
you know keeping ben roethlisberger no i
i think you make all the right points
um you know the one thing i'll say about
big ben and i do believe he was banged
up you know the second half of the year
his arm is still good it's not great
anymore but he can still hit the 20 yard
out
or the deep post 50 yards down the field
with ease
so there is something there you know the
one thing i'll say
you know to to what you're saying
because you said it i mean their defense
is a super bowl defense
i would hope big ben like you talked
about with jj watt would just go wait
this is i want to play because i want to
play my legacy all of those type of
things
and would take you know a huge salary
salary reduction
so maybe they can get a bud duprey back
who's coming off an acl tear too where i
think that might hurt his
ability to get a big time you know
contract on the market and i think
actually favors pittsburgh
to maybe get him back but you said it
and then here's
you know so they're a little stuck in
between one
show me the options that are better that
they can get right now
on on their football team at the
quarterback position they're going to be
in no man's land i think for the most
part in the draft
you know at quarterback at least for the
first rounders there i don't think they
can do anything
the big thing they have to do is do
their best to keep their defense intact
and
a little bit of a disservice to big ben
last year anyways and some of this might
have been his doing right we heard the
rumors that he might have been your run
play was called and he got to the pass
and all those type of things
but they got to get back to balance
football you know one thing i've talked
about with them is
they became predictable within their
predictability and i think i said that
to you during the year
we knew they were going to throw at
every play and then you're like and
they're going to throw every play
five or six yards right here and right
here and right here
and that you know he's not patrick
mahomes or
josh allen or that at this point of his
career they need to get back to running
the ball
protect him and i would think like look
at what tampa bay did with tom brady
if you could run the ball and protect
him he's still going to be able to beat
uh beat defenses with one-on-one
match-ups and his ability to throw the
ball down the field and i think that's
probably where
they came to this this situation right
now good to talk to you chris
and we look forward to your deep dive
into the quarterbacking position because
i will say history's on your side with
picking out who you think will be the
most successful quarterback would you
take herbert over burrow
right now uh yeah i would i definitely
would
you know herbert's special and of course
there's the injury related i love joe
burrow's year
i mean he made a lot of chicken salad at
a chicken you know what
uh but herbert is just big athlete
incredible arm i mean incredible i mean
it's it's josh allen mahomes it might
not have the flare and everything like
that
but his ability to make throws and
awkward positions or people around him
are really good and yeah i think he's a
superstar i really do
thank you chris all right buddy be good
say hi to the guys that's chris sims pro
football talk
co-host with mike florio